Marina Ocean y cobar reaparece en París
la periodista rusa ofreció una
conferencia de prensa en la que expresó
su sentir sobre la guerra en Ucrania y
expuso su experiencia sobre la protesta
pública que provocó su salto a los
reflectores mundiales
tú sabes en el momento en el que la
guerra comenzó tuve un impacto emocional
muy fuerte quería correr con todas las
pancartas que había hasta el centro de
Moscú y gritarlo Tan Alto Como pudiera
el primer día de la guerra decidí que
abandonaría la redacción que me iría a
cualquier parte todos los canales de
oposición Ya habían sido destruidos para
ese momento había una burbuja
propagandística gigante
no a la guerra para en la guerra no
crean en la propaganda les están
mintiendo eso es lo que recitaba la
pancarta que oceánico va mostró en un
famoso canal de televisión rusa en 2022
después de que la emisión saliera del
Aire El paradero de la periodista fue
desconocido durante horas en agosto las
autoridades rusas la condenaron a dos
meses de arresto domiciliario acusada de
propagar falsas noticias sobre las
fuerzas armadas del país quedó en
libertad Un día después al pagar 280
dólares de fianza
Por supuesto que temo por mi vida mis
amigos no paran de llamar y hacer bromas
que prefieres nobichock polonio o un
accidente de coche yo bromeo también
pero intento tomar algunas precauciones
de seguridad
es una de las tantas voces críticas que
han sido censuradas por el gobierno ruso
la incomodidad del Estado ruso con la
divergencia de opiniones pone al
periodismo como una profesión de alto
riesgo dentro de la nación